The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: One of the things
that you should probably have
noticed is as we're moving in
the terms, the problem sets
are getting less well defined.
line And I've seen a lot of
email traffic of the nature of
what should we do with this,
what should we do with that?
For example, suppose
the computer
player runs out of time.
Or the person runs out of
time playing the game.
Should it stop right away?
Should it just give
them zero score?
That's left out of
the problem set.
In part because one of the
things were trying to
accomplish is to have you
folks start noticing
ambiguities in problem
statements.
Because that's life
in computing.
And so this is not like a math
problem set or a physics
problem set.
Or, like a high school physics
lab, where we all know what
the answer should be,
and you could fake
your lab results anyway.
These are things where you're
going to have to kind of
figure it out.
And for most of these things,
all we ask is that you do
something reasonable, and
that you describe what
it is you're doing.
So I don't much care, for
example, whether you give the
human players zero points
for playing after
the time runs out.
Or you say you're done when
Any of that -- thank you,
Sheila -- is ok with me.
Whatever.
What I don't want your
program to do is
crash when that happens.
Or run forever.
Figure out something reasonable
and do it.
And again, we'll see this as an
increasing trend as we work
our way through the term.
The exception will be the next
problem set, which will come
out Friday.
Because that's not a programming
problem.
It's a problem, as you'll see,
designed to give you some
practice at dealing with some
of the, dare I say, more
theoretical concepts we've
covered in class.
Like algorithmic complexity.
That are not readily dealt with
in a prograing problem.
It also deals with issues of
some of the subtleties of
things like aliasing.
So there's no programming.
And in fact, we're not
even going to ask
you to hand it in.
It's a problem set where we've
worked pretty hard to write
some problems that we think will
provide you with a good
learning experience.
And you should just do it
to learn the material.
We'll help you, if you need --
to see the TAs because you
can't do them, by all means make
sure you get some help.
So I'm not suggesting that it's
an optional problem set
that you shouldn't do.
Because you will come to regret
it if you don't do it.
But we're not going
to grade it.
And since we're not going to
grade it, it seems kind of
unfair to ask you
to hand it in.
So it's a short problem set, but
make sure you know how to
do
those problems. OK.
Today, for the rest of the
lecture, we're going to take a
break from the topic of
algorithms, and computation,
and things of the sort.
And do something pretty
pragmatic.
And we're going to talk
briefly about testing.
And at considerable length
about debugging.
I have tried to give this
lecture at the beginning of
the term, at the end
of the term.
Now I'm trying it kind of
a third of the way, or
middle of the term.
I never know the right
time to give it.
These are sort of pragmatic
hints that are useful.
I suspect all of you have found
that debugging can be a
frustrating activity.
My hope is that at this point,
you've experienced enough
frustration that the kind of
pragmatic hints I'm going to
talk about will not be, "yeah
sure, of course." But they'll
actually make sense to you.
We'll see.
OK.
In a perfect world, the weather
would always be like
it's been this week.
The M in MIT would stand
for Maui, instead of
Massachusetts.
Quantum physics would be
easier to understand.
All the supreme court justices
would share our social values.
And most importantly, our
programs would work the first
time we typed them.
By now you may have noticed
that we do not live in an
ideal world.
At least one of those things
I mentioned is not true.
I'm only going to address
the last one.
Why our programs don't work.
And I will leave the supreme
court up to the rest of you.
There is an election
coming up.
Alright, First a few
definitions.
Things I want to make sure we
all understand what they mean.
Validation is a process.
And I want to emphasize
the word process.
Designed to uncover problems and
increase confidence that
our program does what we think
it's intended to do.
I want to emphasize that it will
increase our confidence,
but we can never really be
sure we've got it nailed.
And so it's a process
that goes on and on.
And I also want to emphasize
that a big piece of it is to
uncover problems. So we need to
have a method not designed
to give us unwarranted
confidence.
But in fact warranted confidence
in our programs.
It's typically a combination
of two things.
Testing and reasoning.
Testing, we run our program
on some set of inputs.
And check the answers, and say
yeah, that's what we expected.
But it also involves
reasoning.
About why that's an appropriate
set of inputs to
test it on it.
Have we tested it on
enough inputs?
Maybe just reading the code and
studying it and convincing
ourselves that works.
So we do both of those as part
of the validation process.
And we'll talk about all
of this as we go along.
Debugging is a different
process.
And that's basically the process
of ascertaining why
the program is not working.
Why it's failing to
work properly.
So validation says whoops,
it's not working.
And now we try and figure
out why not.
And then of course, once we
figure out why not, we try and
fix it. but today I'm going to
emphasize not how do you fix
it, but how do you find
out what's wrong.
Usually when you know why it's
not working, it's obvious what
you have to do to
make it work.
There are two aspects of it.
Thus far, the problem sets have
mostly focused on function.
Does it exhibit the functional
behavior?
Does it give you the answer that
you expected it to give?
Often, in practical problems,
you'll spend just as much time
doing performance debugging.
Why is it slow?
Why is it not getting
the answer as fast
as I want it to?
And in fact, in a lot of
industry -- for example, if
you're working on building a
computer game, you'll discover
that in fact the people working
the game will spend
more time on performance
debugging than on getting it
to do the right thing.
Trying to make it do
it fast enough.
Or get to run on the
right processor.
Some other terms we've talked
about is defensive
programming.
And we've been weaving that
pretty consistently
throughout the term.
And that's basically writing
your programs in such a way
that it will facilitate both
validation and debugging.
And we've talked about a
lot of ways we do that.
One of the most important things
we do is we use assert
statements so that we catch
problems early.
We write specifications
of our functions.
We modularize things.
And we'll come back to this.
As every time we introduce a new
programming concept, we'll
relate it back, as we have been
doing consistently, to
defensive programming.
So one of the things I want
you to notice here is that
testing and debugging are
not the same thing.
When we test, we compare an
input output pair to a
specification.
When we debug, we study the
events that led to an error.
I'll return to testing
later in the term.
But I do want to make a couple
of quick remarks with very
broad strokes.
There are basically two
classes of testing.
There's unit testing, where we
validate each piece of the
program independently.
Thus far, for us it's been
testing individual functions.
Later in the term, we'll talk
about unit testing of classes.
The other kind of testing
is integration testing.
Where we put our whole program
together, and we say does the
whole thing work?
People tend to want to rush
in and do this right away.
That's usually a big mistake.
Because usually it
doesn't work.
And so one of the things that
I think is very important is
to always begin by testing
each unit.
So before I try and run my
program, I test each part of
it independently.
And that's because it's
easier to test small
things than big things.
And it's easier to debug small
Eventually, it's a big
program, I run it.
It never works the first time
if it's a big program.
And I end up going back and
doing unit testing anyway, to
try and figure out why
it doesn't work.
So over the years, I've just
convinced myself I might as
well start where I'm
going to end up.
What's so hard about testing?
Why is testing always
a challenge?
Well, you could just try it and
see if it works, right?
That's what testing
is all about.
So we could look at
something small.
Just write a program to find
the max of x and y.
Where x and y are floats.
However many quotes I need.
Well, just see if it works.
Let's test it in all possible
combinations of x and y and
see if we get the
right answer.
Well, as Carl Sagan would have
said, there are billions and
billions of tests we
would have to do.
Or maybe it's billions and
billions and billions.
Pretty impractical.
And it's hard to imagine a
simpler program than this.
So we very quickly realize that
exhaustive testing is
just never feasible for an
interesting program.
So as we look at testing, what
we have to find is what's
called a test suite.
A test suite is small enough
so that we can test it in a
reasonable amount of time.
But also large enough to give
us some confidence.
Later in the term, we'll spend
part of a lecture talking
about, how do we find
such a test suite?
A test suite that will make
us feel good about things.
For now, I just want you to be
aware that you're always doing
this balancing act.
So let's assume we've
run our test suite.
And, sad to say, at least one
of our tests produced an
output that we were
unhappy with.
It took it too long to
generate the output.
Or more likely, it was just
the wrong output.
That gets us to debugging.
So a word about debugging.
Where did the name come from?
Well here's a fun story, at
least. This was one of the
very first recorded bugs in the
history of computation.
Recorded September 9th, 1947,
in case you're interested.
This was the lab book of
Grace Murray Hopper.
Later Admiral Grace
Murray Hopper.
The first female admiral
in the U.S. navy.
Who was also one of the word's
first programmers.
So she was trying to
write this program,
and it didn't work.
It was a complicated program.
It was computing the arctan.
So you can imagine, right?
You had a whole team of people
trying to figure
out how to do arctans.
Times were different
in those days.
And they tried to run it,
and it ran a long time.
Then it basically stopped.
Then they started
the cosine tape.
That didn't work.
Well they couldn't figure
out what was wrong.
And they spent a long time
trying to debug the program.
They didn't apparently
call it debugging.
And then they found
the problem.
In relay number 70, a moth
had been trapped.
And the relay had closed
on the poor creature,
crushing it to death.
The defense department didn't
care about the loss of a moth.
But they did care about
the fact that the
relay was now stuck.
It didn't work.
They removed the moth, and
the program worked.
And you'll see at the bottom, it
says the first actual case
of a bug being found.
And they were very proud
of themselves.
Now it's a wonderful story,
and it is true.
After all, Grace wouldn't
have lied.
But it's not the first use of
the term "bug." And as you'll
see by your handout, I've
attempted tend to trace it.
And the first one I could
find was in 1896.
In a handbook on electricity.
Alright.
Now debugging is a
learned skill.
Nobody does it well
instinctively.
And a large part of being a good
programmer, or learning
to be a good programmer, is
learning how to debug.
And it's one of these things
where it's harder.
It's slow, slow, and you
suddenly have an epiphany.
And you now get the
hang of it.
And I'm hoping that today's
lecture will
help you learn faster.
The nice thing, is once you
learn to debug programs, you
will discover it's a
transferable skill.
And you can use it to debug
other complex systems. So for
example, a laboratory
experience.
Why isn't this experiment
working?
There's a lecture I've given
several times at hospitals, to
doctors, on doing diagnosis of
complex multi illnesses.
And I go through it, and almost
the same kind of stuff
I'm going to talk to you
about, about debugging.
Explaining that it's really
a process of engineering.
So I want to start by disabusing
you of a couple of
myths about bugs.
So myth one is that bugs crawl
into programs. Well it may
have been true in the old
days, when bugs flew or
crawled into relays.
It's not true now.
If there is a bug in the
program, it's there for only
one reason.
You put it there. i.e.
you made a mistake.
So we like to call them bugs,
because it doesn't make us
feel stupid.
But in fact, a better word
would be mistake.
Another myth is that
the bugs breed.
They do not.
If there are multiple bugs in
the program, it's because you
made multiple mistakes.
Not because you made one or
two and they mated and
produced many more bugs.
It doesn't work that way.
That's a good thing.
Typically, even though
they don't breed,
there are many bugs.
And keep in mind that the goal
of debugging is not to
eliminate one bug.
The goal is to move towards
a bug free program.
I emphasize this because it
often leads to a different
debugging strategy.
People can get hung up on sort
of hunting these things down,
and stamping them out,
one at a time.
And it's a little bit like
playing Whack-a-Mole.
Right?
They keep jumping up at you.
So the goal is to figure out a
way to stamp them all out.
Now, should you be proud
when you find a bug?
I've had graduate students come
to me and say I found a
bug in my program.
And they're really proud
of themselves.
And depending on the mood I'm
in, I either congratulate
them, or I say ah, you
screwed up, huh?
Then you had to fix it.
If you find a bug, it probably
means there are more of them.
So you ought to be a
little bit careful.
The story I've heard told is
you're at somebody's house for
dinner, and you're sitting at
the dining room table, then
you hear a [BANG].
And then your hostess walks in
with the turkey in a tray, and
says, "I killed the last
cockroach." Well it wouldn't
increase my appetite, at least.
So be worried about it.
For at least four decades,
people have been building
tools called debuggers.
Things to help you find bugs.
And there are some
built into Idol.
My personal view is
most of them are
not worth the trouble.
The two best debugging tools
are the same now that they
have almost always been.
And they are the print
statement, and reading.
There is no substitute for
reading your code.
Getting good at this is probably
the single most
important skill for debugging.
And people are often
resistant to that.
They'd rather single step
it through using Idol or
something, than just read it and
try and figure things out.
The most important thing to
remember when you're doing all
of this is to be systematic.
That's what distinguishes good
debuggers from bad debuggers.
Good debuggers have evolved a
way of systematically hunting
for the bugs.
And what they're doing as they
hunt, is they're reducing the
search space.
And they do that to localize
the source of the problem.
We've already spent a fair
amount of time this semester
talking about searches.
Algorithms for searching.
Debugging is simply
a search process.
When you are searching a list
to see whether it has an
element, you don't randomly
probe the list, hoping to find
whether or not it's there.
You find some way of
systematically going through
the list. Yet, I often see
people, when they're
debugging, proceeding at what,
to me, looks almost like a
random fashion of looking
for the bug.
That is a problem that
may not terminate.
So you need to be careful.
So let's talk about how
we go about being
systematic, as we do this.
So debugging starts when
we find out that
there exists a problem.
So the first thing to do is to
study the program text, and
ask how could it have produced
this result?
So there's something
subtle about the
way I've worded this.
I didn't ask, why didn't it
produce the result I wanted it
to produce?
Which is sort of the question
we'd immediately like to ask.
Instead, I asked why did it
produce the result it did.
So I'm not asking myself
what's wrong?
Or how could I make it right?
I'm asking how could
have done this?
I didn't expect it to do this.
If you understand why
it did what it did,
you're half way there.
The next big question you ask,
is it part of a family?
This gets back to the question
of trying to get the program
to be bug free.
So for example, oh, it did this
because it was aliasing,
where I hadn't expected it.
Or some side effect of some
mutation with lists.
And then I say, oh you
know I've used lists
all over this program.
I'll bet this isn't the
only place where
I've made this mistake.
So you say well, rather than
rushing off and fixing this
one bug, let me pull back and
ask, is this a systematic
mistake that I've made
throughout the program?
And if so, let's fix them
all at once, rather
than one at a time.
And that gets me to the
final question.
How to fix it.
When I think about debugging,
I think about it in terms of
what you learned in
high school as
the scientific method.
Actually, I should
ask the question.
Maybe I'm dating myself.
Do they still teach
the scientific
method in high school?
Yes, alright good.
All is not lost with the
American educational system.
So what does the scientific
method tell us to do?
Well it says you first
start by studying
the available data.
In this case, the available
data are the test results.
And by the way, I mean
all the test results.
Not just the one where it didn't
work, but also the ones
where it did.
Because maybe the program
worked on some
inputs and not on others.
And maybe by understanding why
it worked on a and not on b,
you'll get a lot of insight
that you won't if you just
focus on the bug.
You'll also feel a little bit
better knowing your program
works on at least something.
The other big piece of available
data we have is, of
course, the program text.
As you the study the program
text, keep in mind that you
don't understand it.
Because if you really did, you
wouldn't have the bug.
So read it with sort
of a skeptical eye.
You then form a hypothesis
consistent with all the data.
Not just some of the data,
but all of the data.
And then you design and run
a repeatable experiment.
Now what is the thing we learned
in high school about
how to design these
experiments?
What must this experiment have
the potential to do, to be a
valid scientific experiment?
Somebody?
What's the key thing?
It must have the potential
to refute the hypothesis.
It's not a valid experiment if
it has no chance of showing
that my hypothesis is flawed.
Otherwise why bother
running it?
So it has to have that.
Typically it's nice if
it can have useful
intermediate results.
Not just one answer
at the end.
So we can sort of check the
progress of the code.
And we must know what the result
is supposed to be.
Typically when you run an
experiment, you say, and I
think the answer will be x.
If it's not x, you've refuted
the hypothesis.
This is the place where people
typically slip up in debugging.
They don't think in advance
what they expect
the result to be.
And therefore, they are not
systematic about interpreting
the results.
So when someone comes to me,
and they're about to do a
test, I ask them, what do you
expect your program to do?
And if they can't answer that
question, I say well, before
you even run it, have
an answer to that.
Why might repeatability
be an issue?
Well as we'll see later in the
term, we're going to use a lot
of randomness in a lot of our
programs. Where we essentially
do the equivalent of flipping
coins or rolling dice.
And so the program may
do different things
on different runs.
We'll see a lot of that, because
it's used a lot in
modern computing.
And so you have to figure out
how to take that randomness
out of the experiment.
And yet get a valid test.
Sometimes it can be timing.
If you're running multiple
processes.
That's why your operating
systems and your personal
computers often crash for
no apparent reason.
Just because two things happen
to, once in a while, occur at
the same time.
And often there's human input.
And people have to type
things out of it.
So you want to get
rid of that.
And we'll talk more
about this later.
Particularly when we get
to using randomness.
About how to debug programs
where random
choices are being made.
Now let's think about designing
the experiment itself.
The goal here, there
are two goals.
Or more than two.
One is to find the simplest
input that
will provoke the bug.
So it's often the case that a
program will run a long time,
and then suddenly a
bug will show up.
But you don't want to have to
run it a long time, every time
you have a hypothesis.
So you try and find a
smaller input that
will produce the problem.
So if your word game doesn't
work when the words are 12
letters long, instead of
continuing to debug 12 letter
hands, see if you can make it
fail on a three letter hand.
If you can figure out why fails
on three letters instead
of 12, you'll be more
than half way
to solving the problem.
What I typically do is I start
with the input that provoked
the problem, and I keep making
it smaller and smaller.
And see if I can't get
it to show up.
The other thing you want to
do is find the part of the
program that is most
likely at fault.
In both of these cases,
I strongly
recommend binary search.
We've talked about this binary
search a lot already.
Again, the trick is, if you
can get rid of half of the
data at each shot, or half of
the code at each shot., you'll
quickly converge on where
the problem is.
So I now want to work through
an example where we can see
this happening.
So this is the example
on the handout.
I've got a little program
called Silly.
And it's called Silly
because it's really
a rather ugly program.
It's certainly not the
right way to write a
program to do this.
But it will let us illustrate
a few points.
So the trick, what we're going
to go through here, is this
whole scientific process.
And see what's going on.
So let's try running Silly.
So this is to test whether
a list is a palindrome.
So we'll put one as the
first element, maybe a
is the second element.
And one is the third element.
And just return, it's done.
It is a palindrome.
That make sense.
The list one a one reads
the same from the
front or from the back.
So that's good.
Making some progress.
Let's try it again.
And now let's do one, a, two.
Whoops.
It tells me it is
a palindrome.
Well, it isn't really.
I have a bug.
Alright.
Now what do I do?
Well I'm going to use binary
search to see if I
can't find this bug.
As I go through, I'm going to
try and eliminate half of the
code at each step.
And the way I'm going to
do that is by printing
intermediate values, as I go
part way through the code.
I'm going to try and predict
what the value is going to be.
And then see if, indeed,
I get what I predicted.
Now, as I do this, I'm going
to use binary search.
I'm going to start somewhere
near the middle of the code.
Again, a lot of times,
people don't do that.
And they'll test an intermediate
value near the
end or near the beginning.
Kind of in the hope of getting
there in one shot.
And that's like kind of hoping
that the element you're
searching for is the first in
the list and the last in the
list. Maybe.
But part of the process of
being systematic is not
assuming that I'm going
to get a lucky guess.
But not even thinking really
hard at this point.
But just pruning the
search space.
Getting rid of half
at each step.
Alright.
So let's start with
the bisection.
So we're going to choose a point
about in the middle of
my program.
That's close to the middle.
It might even be the middle.
And we're going to see,
well all right.
The only thing I've done in this
part of the program, now
I'm going to go and read the
code, is I've gotten the user
to input a bunch of data.
And built up the list
corresponding to the three
items that the user entered.
So the only intermediate value
I have here is really res.
So I'm going to, just so when
I'm finished I know what it is
that I think I've printed.
But in fact maybe I'll do even
more than that here.
Let me say what I think
it should be.
And then we'll see if it is.
So I think I put in
one a two, right?
Or one a two?
So it should be something
like one, a, two.
So I predicted what answer
I'm expecting to get.
And I've put it in my
debugging code.
And now I'll run it and
see what we get.
We'll save it.
Well all right, a
syntax error.
This happens.
And there's a syntax error.
I see.
Because I've got a
quote in a quote.
Alright I'm just going
to do that.
What I expected.
So what have I learned?
I've learned that with high
probability, the error is not
in the first part
of the program.
So I can now ignore that.
So now I have these six lines.
So we'll try and go in
the middle of that.
See if we can find it here.
And notice, by the way, that I
commented out the previous
debugging line, rather
than got rid of it.
Since I'm not sure I won't
need to go back to it.
So what should I look at here?
Well there are a couple of
interesting intermediate
values here, right?
There's tmp.
And there's res.
Never type kneeling.
Right?
I find something to tmp.
And I need to make sure maybe
I haven't messed up res.
Now it would be easy to assume,
don't bother looking
at [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Because the code doesn't
change res.
Well remember, that I started
this with a bug.
That means it was something
I didn't understand.
So I'm going to be cautious
and systematic.
And say let's just
print them both.
And see whether they're okay.
Now, let's do this.
So it says tmp is two a one,
and res is two a one.
Well let's think it.
Is this what we wanted, here?
What's the basic idea
behind this program?
How is it attempting to work?
Well what it's attempting to do,
and now is when I have to
stand back and form a hypothesis
and think about
what's going on, is it gets in
the list, it reverses the
list, and then sees whether
the list and the
reverse were identical.
If so it was a palindrome,
otherwise it wasn't.
So I've now done this, and
what do you think?
Is this good or bad?
Is this what I should
be getting?
No.
What's wrong?
Somebody? yeah.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Somehow I wanted to --
Got to work on those hands.
I didn't want to change res.
So, I now know that the bug has
got to be between these
two print statements.
I'm narrowing it down.
It's getting a little silly,
but you know I'm going to
really be persistent and just
follow the rules here of
binary search, rather than
jumping to conclusions.
Well clearly what I probably
want to do here is what?
Print these same two things.
See what I get.
Whoops.
I have to, of course, do that.
Otherwise it just tells
me that Silly
happens to be a function.
Alright.
How do I feel about
this result?
I feel pretty good here.
Right?
The idea was to make a
copy of res and temp.
And sure enough, they're
both the same.
What I expected them to be.
So I know the bug
is not above.
Now I'm really honing in.
I now know it's got to be
between these two statements.
So let's put it there.
Aha.
It's gone wrong.
So now I've narrowed the
bug down to one place.
I know exactly which
statement it's in.
So something has happened
there that
wasn't what I expected.
Who wants to tell me
what that bug is?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Bad throw, good catch.
So this is a classic error.
I've not made a copy of the
list. I've got an alias of the
list. This was the thing
that tripped up many
of you on the quiz.
And really what I should
have done is this.
Now we'll try it.
Ha.
It's not a palindrome.
So small silly little exercise,
but I'm hoping that
you've sort of seen how
by being patient.
Patience is an important part
of the debugging process.
I have not rushed.
I've calmly and slowly
narrowed the search.
Found where the statement
is, and then fixed it.
And now I'm going to go hunt
through the rest of my code to
look for places where I used
assignment, when I should have
use cloning as part
of the assignment.
The bug, the family here, is
failure to clone when I should
have cloned.
Thursday we'll talk a little bit
more about what to do once
we've found the bug, and then
back to algorithms.